can i go a totally different direction
anywhere you want to go because callers
are waiting by this this is a question
that i think that you're qualified to
answer
i'd appreciate an answer uh this has to
do with mathematics religion sure uh
evolution
uh the great um american scholar
philosopher that we talked about earlier
by the name of joe rogan had a bit back
in 2009 he did a stand-up comedy you
know joe rogan
by name okay he says sends his regards
um he had a bit uh or a stand-up special
called um
talking monkeys in space
where he's having a conversation right
you got the title he's having a
conversation with a guy
about his faith
and he uh the guy's like i came from
jesus bro like straight up i'm from
jesus i have faith i came from jesus and
joe goes how do you know so much aren't
you like 30 like how do you know so much
you know and joe rogan basically says
look uh you know what i do uh i don't
know everything but there's uh i like to
memorize [ __ ] that a lot of smart people
have come up with and i basically just
kind of read what they've already kind
of put together and i just kind of
regurgitate that and one of the things
that they found is something called the
human genome familiar with this concept
the human genome so basically he says
what they found in the human genome is
that we us humans are 96
chimpanzee 96 chimpanzee this is his bit
and he says and sort of jokingly now if
i gave you a sandwich
and it was 96
[ __ ]
and four percent ham are you willing to
call that a ham sandwich and basically
saying we're monkeys bro we're freaking
monkeys flying through space
and he basically saying that that's the
evolution right there you're a
mathematician is joe rogan right here
and please refute him if he's wrong
there was so many vivid voices emerging
just now i'm not quite sure who's saying
what um the doctrine that uh
are we did we come from monkeys are we
96 percent is there an evolutionary path
from our
simian ancestors to you yeah of course
there is nobody doubts that i know some
people do do without that that's why i'm
asking
not here okay we're not about it you're
taking a stand and saying that we did
come from apes but that's
uncontroversial well it is though i feel
no so you're taking a stand and saying
that we did come from apes you're wrong
it's not controversial nobody when
pressed will really deny
because you have to endow come from apes
with a certain amount of content
if you mean come from apes by a process
of random variation and natural
selection i'll say wait a second i don't
i don't think that's quite accurate if
you mean to say there's overwhelming
evidence that there are evolutionary
transitions we can walk the human line
back
and actually see
the patterns emerging from both the
fossil record and the paleontological
record
of course of course that's true
there is no evidence
that it is anything other than that
which is perfectly compatible with the
doctrine of creation by the way
how's that because that's
incompatible no evolution and
creationism i thought that's a different
ends of the spectrum it depends what you
mean by evolution if you mean you can
trace your ancestors back and sooner or
later you will run into something that
looks markedly unlike you but in a
certain way resembles you sure that's
uncon uncontroversial you can do it
genetically you can do it in terms of
the fossil record if you mean on the
other hand that at a certain point
something new emerged
for which we have very little
understanding
that too can be argued
for example
although there is a striking sequence
similarity it's it's certainly not 98
it's somewhere in the 80s
and there are a lot of questions about
how those sequences are mapped one to
the other don't forget until very
recently we did not have a complete
human genome
but if you look at
human beings
and you look at our presumptively
nearest ancestors
there's an unfathomably large distance
between us
unfathomably large we are completely
different
we have properties not seen in the rest
of the animal kingdom we have behaviors
not seen in the rest of the
animal kingdom we have a cognitive
apparatus that's not seen in the rest of
the animal kingdom
so on the one hand yes i can
go backwards progressively
chasing
ancestors and saying well there's a line
of derivation that makes perfect sense
no point in disguising that but at the
same time when we reach the stage of
human beings
there's an explosion of very interesting
and very isolated properties both those
things are true if you enjoyed this
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]
you